disait cette passation de pouvoir ça a
été un moment solennel il ya eu beaucoup
d'émotion et d'applaudissements
également comment est-ce que vous
réagissez cette passation de pouvoir
écoutez moi je voudrais une salué
l'action d'edouard philippe pendant tous
ces mois toute cette semaine à matignon
c'est un homme qui a montré une grande
humilité une grande capacité d'écouté et
une grande attention aux français dans
des moments difficiles tel que nous
l'avons vécu au travers du la pandémie
due qu'aux vite 19 septembre
d'ailleurs on le voit les sondages l'ont
le portent de plus en plus je pense
vertement jeu je regrette son départ je
regrette son départ nous nous sommes
entretenus dans les couloirs du sénat
mardi
et je lui ai fait part de mon souhait
qu'il rêve et il m'a simplement adressé
un clin d'oeil donc j'avais compris que
ce n'était pas du tout évident je tiens
véritablement à regretter son départ
on a vu cette passation de pouvoirs
assez on vend beaucoup d'émotion de la
parade edouard philippe de l'humour
également deux hommes différents
est ce que ces deux styles et deux
manières de gouverner selon vous écouter
on va voir ce que va pouvoir réaliser
monsieur caf tacle j'ai fait un haut
fonctionnaire
peu connu personnellement je ne le
connais pas mais jamais je n'ai entendu
de mal le concernant et quand on regarde
sa bibliographie
on est quand même frappé que même s'il
fait un haut fonctionnaire depuis très
longtemps dans une petite commune prades
et bien il a eu lui aussi l'humilité de
s'investir au plus proche de nos
concitoyens et je le fais par des
collègues président jeu je me suis
empressé de savoir qu'ils étaient toutes
sensibilités confondues
tout le monde en inventer si je peux
dire la mairie c'est quelqu'un qui
ressemble un peu à mon sens à edouard
philippe
c'est quelqu'un encore une fois frappé
d'humilité des coups tu es le roi que
dans une société dans une france très
fracturée à vif avec les pilotes des
gilet jaune avec je dirais les les
les violences qui malheureusement émail
trop nos villes et nos banlieues je
pense que nous avons besoin de cette
fois de ses enfants ce tranquille qui
connaissait personnellement edouard
philippe
avec quelques mots comment comment est
ce que vous qualifiez le bilan de notre
ancien premier ministre après plusieurs
années où où la france a traversé
vendant ses vents et marées écoutez il a
tenu bon avec je dirais des orientations
qui sont celles du printemps de la
république qui on le devine n était pas
forcément les fiennes mais c'est un
homme d'une grande loyauté
il a il a fait preuve je vous dis
village et transcrire dans les faits
avec je vous dis également ses traits
d'humour que vous avez souligné
mais sa grande loyauté sa grande
simplicité mais c'était pas une
simplicité ou noyauté feinte
c'est un normand comme moi donc ce sont
des gens qui parlent peu qui agit je
pense que on entendra à nouveau parler
de lui son retrait ou son retour sur les
terres candidature en 2000 en deux et
pourquoi pas et pourquoi pas la droite
la droite est en recherche si je puis
dire de deux personnalités et nous avons
découvert un premier ministre est un
homme efficace et je vous dis qu'ils
respectent eux il faut recoudre les
territoires comme dit le président
larcher
il faut rassembler nos concitoyens il
faut assurer je crois que c'est un homme
qui a tué faire tout cela alors que
jeudi il a d'abord été fidèle au
président de la république et on a bien
vu au travers ça a été d'ailleurs
l'objet de notre discussion mardi au
sénat en aparté j'ai bien vu qu'il y
avait un clivage lors des orientations
de la convention citoyenne sur le climat
où on sentait que ce n'était pas entre
guillemets noël loin s'en faut sa tasse
de thé
je ne vous en dirai pas plus c'était
l'objet de notre conversation
jean bizet roseaux à jean castex un
petit peu inconnu du grand public comme
de droite élu local et bon connaisseur
de l'état qu'est ce qu'il attend pour la
rentrée quels sont les gros dossiers qui
l'attendent pour cette rentrée après
après cette épidémie ducobu 19 entraîné
des files de véhicules sur le plan
social parce que la problématique
dégager les jaunes couve encore
difficile parce que l'état de droit
n'existe plus en france
on l'a vu avec les toutes les bagarres
qui lie à dans les banlieues
je crois très sincèrement aussi que nous
allons avoir des plans de licenciements
multiples et variées
quelle que soit la dimension du plan de
relance qui est une dimension inégalée
totalement inégal et mais on voit très
bien si vous voulez que la france a
péniblement allongé 40 milliards d'euros
si vous voulez pour lutter contre les
conséquences de cette pandémie sur le
plan social sur le plan économique
quand l'allemagne elle il y à consacrer
140 milliards d'euros donc il va falloir
que le premier ministre au travers si je
puis dire de la politique européenne
parce que ça ne se résout plus haut
niveau des états nations et bien et
c'est d'éviter cette fragmentation du
marché unique et ajoutez à cela un break
sip
ça mon frère est difficile voire dur
donc le premier ministre a un énorme
chantier à la fois je vous dis social
économique et si en plus au niveau
environnemental
eh bien on s'oriente vers de la
décroissance parce que c'est soit
véritablement les orientations de la
convention citoyenne pour le poulain je
suis très inquiet pour la rentrée
merci jean visait pour cette analyse nos
politiques je rappelle que vous êtes
sénateur et l'air de la manche président
est de la commission des affaires
européennes du sénat